d'un sujet sensible
j'ai marché un peu sur les eaux où la
confusion est facile je vais essayer de
partager avec vous un regard un peu
différent sur l'accueil ou encore
l'intégration de nouvel arrivant moi
même je suis issu des migrations et je
conçois l'immigration comme un privilège
et non un droit
cette conception m'amène à vous
présenter la démarche d'accueil que je
privilégie
ma démarche d'accueil comporte des trois
volets suivants la relation atteint
culturel gagnante la coopération
effective et le maintien de l'équité
face à une réalité plurielle
en ce qui concerne la relation à tokyo
interculturel gagnante
rappelons nous qu aucune culture n'est
bonne ou mauvaise
seul le contexte donne la pertinence à
la culture dans une société
individualiste les valeurs encourager
son l'autonomie et la réussite
personnelle dans une société
collectiviste les valeurs encourager son
l'interdépendance et la solidarité dans
une société individualiste
on élève ses enfants afin qu'ils
accèdent rapidement à leur indépendance
dans une société collectiviste on élève
ses enfants afin qu'ils deviennent des
membres actifs dans la vie familiale
ce qui l'amène à dire qu une culture
différente peut être considérées comme
inappropriées au contexte
en effet les valeurs culturelles ne sont
pas universelles et par conséquent elles
nécessitent d'être apprises
l'enjeu du nouvel arrivant fait
comprendre une nouvelle culture
sur l'enjeu de l'accueillant c'est
d'accueillir chaleureusement le nouvel
arrivant sans s'oublier pour autant
l'accueillons pourrez partager sa
culture avec nouvel arrivant et ainsi
faire vivre sa culture
comment faire vivre et faire vivre sa
culture et comment faire vivre et rendre
accessible la culture tout simplement en
la transmettant de manière naturelle
dans le quotidien
retenons une chose nos évidences
culturelles ne sont pas toujours des
évidences pour les personnes qui
arrivent d'ailleurs prenons l'exemple de
la distance physique toléré entre deux
personnes au québec
cette fameuse bulle qui consiste à ne
pas rentrer dans l'espace physique de
son interlocuteur ce code culturel m'a
donné des sueurs froides à mon arrivée
dans le pays
la question cruciale que je me posais
qu'est ce qui va m'arriver si je rentre
dans cette bulle et en même temps je me
disais j'ai pas le droit de blesser la
personne qui m'accueille si gentiment
c'est là que j'aurais voulu avoir des
éléments de repères comment donner des
éléments de repères
comme vous voyez les évidences
culturelles peuvent peuvent être vécue
différemment par le nouvel arrivant il
est donc nécessaire de lui donner des
éléments de repères sous l'angle de
l'information pourquoi sous l'angle de
l'information afin de provoquer un
intérêt à changer en fait percevoir une
règle sous l'angle de l'information
faciliterait l'appropriation celle ci
c'est le principe du changement
je suis capable de changer mes habitudes
à partir du moment où je perçois un
avantage dans ce changement est là
mais résistance disparaissent en fait
l'information est perçue comme un
avantage est la règle peut être perçue
comme une perte
comme vous pouvez voir le changement
n'est pas facile les principes de la
relation ta culturel gagnante porte sur
la responsabilité de l'accueillant de
transmettre sa culture sous l'angle de
l'information et l'enjeu est la
responsabilité pardon du nouvel arrivant
c'est d'adopter les codes culturels
transmis cette responsabilité partagée
facilite un établissement d'une relation
authentique et seine seine cela veut
dire une relation où il n'y a pas de
frustration ni de l'un ni de l'autre
intéressons nous intéressons nous
maintenant la coopération effective
quand on donne ou par une coopération
effective la coopération effective
c'est de trouver des moyens d'action qui
favorise la transmission la culture par
la société d'accueil
quels seraient les moyens à privilégier
pourquoi je suggère que la transmission
de la culture se fasse par les
accueillants j'entends par accueillant
les citoyens québécois et les québécois
issus de l'immigration ayant un vécu de
plus de cinq ans dans le pays
pourquoi cinq ans c'est une moyenne
consensuel identifiés dans le monde de
l'immigration il s'agit d'une moyenne en
fait
l'appropriation des codes culturels
nécessite du temps et du vécu
ce constat n'est pas toujours compris
par le nouvel arrivant qui a une
une à trois années dans le pays pour lui
il est intégré mais il n'a pas
conscience que son intégration n'est que
fonctionnel par exemple imaginez vous
suivre un guide dans un musée et que
celui ci ne possède qu'une connaissance
fonctionnelle du musée il va pouvoir
vous orienter vers les toilettes vous
dire que le tableau est fake de la
peinture et que l'objet devant vous
brille mais ce que vous ne riez pas
préférer un guide qui vous parle du
contexte historique de la vie de
l'artiste ou encore les techniques à
l'origine de l'oeuvre d'art
c'est ce que j'entends par intégration
fonctionnelle versus intégration dans
son intégralité au niveau de
l'intégration s'est pas toujours si
facile
revenons maintenant à l'accueil de
nouvel arrivant comme vous avez compris
l'accueil du nouvel arrivant passe par
les citoyens comment l'accueil du nouvel
arrivant va passer par les citoyens le
citoyen à peu prendre un rôle actif et
se sentir partie prenante dans la dans
l'intégration à condition que l'on donne
les moyens
par exemple un citoyen actif ou retraité
qui agirait à titre de guide auprès du
nouvel arrivant pour l'informer des
comportements souhaité et ce dans la vie
de tous les jours
le guide n'est en aucun cas un
moralisateur il est là pour donner des
repères culturels précieux la
transmission de la culture peut se faire
en tout temps
elle peut même exister au delà d'un
cadre formel
par exemple un voisin qui informerait un
nouvel arrivant de manière courtoise et
chaleureuse que la propreté des rues
après le passage de chiens en laisse et
très apprécié au québec ou encore même
si une maison n'a pas de clôture le
respect de propriété est implicite
j'ajouterai un autre acteur l'entreprise
l'entreprise
l'entreprise joue un rôle important
également
je suggère à l'entreprise d'inclure le
partagent une culture commune à son
accueil
comment transmettre et partager une
culture commune il suffit de formaliser
la culture ou encore l'adn de
l'entreprise pour identifier l'adn de
l'entreprise
j'ai mis en place un concept
que j'ai appelé la culture dans les murs
pourquoi dans les murs et non sur les
murs la distinction je fais c'est que
sur les murs et ce qui est apparent est
dans les murs c'est ce qui n'est pas
apparent le concept consiste à élaborer
un guide sur les évidences culturel
organisationnel et sur les repères
culturels nationaux
ce guide permet un partage d'une culture
commune est ainsi vite les malentendus
culturels
les principaux malentendus culturels que
l'on peut rencontrer dans une entreprise
portent sur les modes de raisonnement
les modes de communication la conception
différente quant à la relation haïr
archi le travail des équipes
autant de situations où les différences
culturelles existent mais attention cela
ne veut pas dire que tous les arrivants
provenant d'un même pays possède toutes
les caractéristiques de leur pays
initial ça reste des individus et il
faut toujours tenir compte de la
variable individuelle
oui il ya une culture nationale qui
existe mais il ya également une culture
individuelle une culture un vie
individuelle c'est la culture sociale
c'est la culture générationnel et c'est
également la culture de métier et dans
mon concept
j'ai tenu compte cette culture de métier
car on sait que c'est un élément
fédérateur pour rassembler les gens
comment on rassemble les gens en
cherchant des éléments communs la
culture de métier dans plupart des dans
la plupart des métiers techniques
elle est universelle c'est comme ça
qu'on rapproche les gens
revenons à mon concept
il est pensé comme un processus visant à
ce que la rive ans le nouvel arrivant
pardon trouve sa place et ce en
respectant une harmonie organisationnel
l'accueil du nouvel arrivant nécessite
que tous les acteurs convergent dans la
même direction
je suis fier que le misérabilisme ou
encore la victimisation soit banni du
vocabulaire de l'arrivant et de
l'accueillant maintenant passons à mon
troisième axe maintenir une équité face
à une réalité plurielle l'équité passe
avant tout par une relation de confiance
basée sur une relation gagnant gagnant
il est primordial que le l'accueillant
et du nouvel arrivant puisse établir des
rapports égalitaires et éviter de tomber
dans le rapport de force ou encore la
surenchère quand l'entreprise pense j'ai
besoin de mon candidat plus qu'il a
besoin de moi je ne pense pas que cela
facilite leurs rapports égalitaires et
peu et cela peut même engendrer des
illusions voir des désillusions tant au
niveau de l'entreprise qu'au niveau de
la rive ans sachez par exemple que
depuis ces dernières années en europe
une crise économique sévit donc face à
cela la demande d'immigration est en
augmentation pour le canada et pour le
québec
les raisons évoquées par les nouveaux
arrivants pour venir ici
son jeu envie de trouver du travail au
canada au québec car j'ai envie de
travailler là bas donc il ya une réelle
motivation à venir ici par conséquent
les nouveaux arrivants ont autant besoin
des entreprises que les entreprises ont
besoin d'eux il est donc inutile de
jouer le jeu de la séduction mais plutôt
dès le départ
instaurer une relation qui respecte un
juste équilibre entre les devoirs et les
droits individuels ce type de relation
va faciliter une relations
interculturelles scène une relation
basée sur l'équité est un élément
fondamental pour éviter le sentiment ou
encore la perception d'injustice de la
part des accueillants vis-à-vis des
nouveaux arrivants une relation
authentique c'est aimer l'autre non pas
parce qu'il a un privilège mais parce
qu'on l'a reconnu à travers la relation
dont je ne pense pas que si on privilège
qui que ce soit on va créer une relation
authentique la représentation de nouvel
arrivant n'est pas toujours juste et
réaliste
il est important de ne pas tomber dans
les clichés
le nouvel arrivant est super diplômés
c'est un sauveur ou encore le nouvel
arrivant est une personne incompétente
la personne nouvel arrivant est un
individu à part entière avec ses forces
et ses faiblesses
il est toujours important de regarder
l'individu comme il est et surtout ne
pas avoir d illusions la relation que tu
allais pas authentique c'est parce que
les individus
ils ont des attentes mutuellement
alors c'est sûr que si on dit le
l'immigrant et la personne qui va sauver
ou la personne qui va peut-être aller au
delà de la pénurie
c'est sûr que c'est important je dirais
que accueillir autrement c'est avant
tout d'abord regarder la vidéo sa
globalité c'est se positionner comme as
comme son égal et c'est resté intègre
avec soi même
pour conclure je dirais qu'à cueillir
autrement c'est miser sur une
responsabilité partagée incluant les
devoirs les droits individuels
c'est transmettre une culture au
quotidien et c'est de favoriser l'équité
afin d'éviter la perception ou encore le
sentiment d'injustice chez l'accueillant
autant que celle nouvel arrivant merci